BRIAN MATIASH: Thank you very
much everyone for joining us
here today.
My name is Brian Matiash.
I am the community manager
for Google+ Photos.
And I'm actually really excited
when I found out that
Jaime was coming.
I first kind of became aware of
Jaime shortly after Google+
launched about two years ago.
We just celebrated our
two-year anniversary.
And as you can kind of see, it's
not surprising why anyone
would really kind of want
to follow Jaime's work.
The photography that Jaime
shares is beautiful obviously.
But it's also a really
interesting combination of
elegance and provocativeness.
And I find that to be
something that you
don't see too often.
There's a really creative
methodology here.
And as I got to know Jaime
better through Hangouts that
we've been on together over the
past few years and also
even just at dinner, one of
the things that strikes me
most about Jaime, if I had to
summarize it, it wouldn't be
actually photographer.
It would be artist.
And that's because Jaime's
not just a photographer.
In fact, I think Jaime told me
that music is the first and
foremost
Jaime composes his own music.
And it's really awesome.
A lot of times when you see
these videos that he puts out,
his music is in the
background.
But he's also a designer.
And if you do seek out these
kinds of videos, these
time-lapse videos of his
editing, you'll see that
musician, obviously
photographer, but also kind of
like a stylistic editor.
These are words that kind
of come to mind.
He is a mad scientist
with Photoshop.
So with that, I want
to introduce my
friend Jaime to present.
So let's give him a little bit
of a round of applause.
JAIME IBARRA: I was going to
seamlessly segue into this
video I was going to
show you guys.
I don't know how to gracefully
get into it.
It's like, could I
just hit play?
I think it gives a brief
overview of kind of what I do.
So does anybody want
to watch a video?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
JAIME IBARRA: I don't normally
drive a Mac so
bear with me here.
Since we're not really listening
to the audio on
there, this is just a brief
kind of overview.
Basically what I do, I start
with the photo obviously.
And then, go from there.
I'm kind of producing
my own stock.
A lot of times I'm shooting
things that are going to be
elements in a photo.
I do a lot of compositing.
We don't really see any of that
in this particular photo.
Everything was pretty
much in place.
If anything, we just removed
a bunch of stuff.
The only thing I added was--
well, you see it, this hair.
And it was a hot day.
What was it?
It was 104 outside that day, not
counting whatever heat was
radiating off that asphalt.
And it was cooking.
So I think if your head did look
good earlier that day, it
certainly stopped
at that point.
So no worries.
I just painted some in.
So that's about all I can
about that really.
And I think I'd be dead in the
water without Photoshop and
without my post-production
stuff.
And I'm OK with that.
My background is that of
a graphic designer.
I was doing that for years
and years and years.
I remember Photoshop
before there was
such a thing as layers.
And that gives you an idea
about how far back that
Photoshop and I go.
We're old friends,
mostly friends.
And that's just a
little overview.
And I was going to talk
about this photo,
but you saw the video.
So we started with this--
and delay.
What are we doing?
Let me go to just
the next one.
And what I did today was I
really had a hard time trying
to figure out what I wanted
to talk about exactly.
One thing that people that know
me know all too well, is
I am the most hopelessly and
unrepentantly right-brained
person you'll likely
ever meet.
My brain wanders all the time.
I lack the ability to think
in a procedural
way most of the time.
But although sometimes I beat
myself up about that, I think
if I weren't that way,
I don't think my work
would be what it is.
And that goes with
the photography.
It goes with music.
It goes with anything I do.
I'm kind of a stream of
consciousness kind of guy.
Just whatever comes in, as it
comes in, I just sort of take
it and let it become whatever
it is going to become.
And as far as photography goes,
I'm definitely not a
technician at all.
I own one camera.
I own one lens for
that camera.
And I'm totally OK with that.
Like that lens is my eye and
I've gotten used to seeing how
I see things through it.
And this photo right here
actually goes back to probably
a time when I first
started out.
And I don't know if anybody
knows who the person
in this photo is.
But she is--
AUDIENCE: Mata Hari.
JAIME IBARRA: What's that?
AUDIENCE: Mata Hari?
JAIME IBARRA: Well, Mata Hari
had a lot of influence.
This is Rachel Brice.
Rachel Brice is responsible
for what is now known as
'tribal belly dance." And if you
see belly dancers nowadays
that dress like this, they're
basically copying what Rachel
Brice invented.
And it was really cool that I
got to shoot with her for
about three minutes in her
dressing room at a show.
She got wind that I was
in the crowd and
invited me back there.
And you're looking at the end
result of that shoot.
But to show you the before,
it's not nearly as cool.
This is her in her
dressing room.
I shot this with
my Canon 300D.
That's the original
Digital Rebel.
My 6.1 megapixels of awesome.
And there was a little plastic
kit lens that came with it.
I really didn't know what
I was doing at the time.
The only light in that room is
just the fluorescent ceiling
lights and that was all.
And I think now I wouldn't have
shot this photo the way
that I shot it here.
But this is back in--
I literally didn't really
know what I was doing.
But you can see how much the
post-production came in and
saved the day with this one.
So that's Rachel Brice.
That was my first.
The first photo shoot that I
did, I actually bragged about.
There is people that would kill
to get a shoot with her.
And I don't know how
I managed to do it.
But that's Rachel Brice.
That was my first moderate
success story.
Let me talk a little bit
about this one this.
This is my lovely fiance, who
is sitting right in front of
me, next to Michael Bonocore.
Lucky, lucky you, you're
closer than I am.
MICHAEL BONOCORE:
And your camera.
JAIME IBARRA: And my camera.
And this Shantia.
She's an amazing, amazing,
amazing model.
And we oftentimes will approach
designers who just
make interesting clothes or make
interesting accessories.
And we found a lady--
do you know her name?
I forget her name.
SHANTIA VENEY: Kelly Emporium.
JAIME IBARRA: Kelly Emporium,
who agreed to let us
photograph the headdress
that she made.
It's actually made of
leather, was it?
SHANTIA VENEY: Un-huh.
JAIME IBARRA: And we
had a fun with it.
But this is the final image.
What the actual headdress looks
like when we started was
simply that.
And it's pretty cool
on its own.
But you can see the amount of
post-production that was done.
The background was a painting
that a pretty amazing artist
in Germany that I know-- and
agreed to allow me to use that
as the background
for the photo.
And then the make-up
is kind of styled.
That's an example of one
breeze stirs another.
And I think had you not done
your make-up that way, I don't
think I would have done
that background.
The background came as a result
of you having done your
make-up that way, with the blue
fading up into the black.
And then the gold just as
a yellow meets blue.
It's just a complementary color
path that I just think
worked really well
with that photo.
And there's a nice example.
I don't know how long it
took me to do that.
So I spent a good two days
trying to figure out how to
extend the--
I don't know what you call them,
tendricles, the things
that are coming out
behind the mask.
But once I figured it
out, they ended up
looking pretty good.
This one, I think this is the
first time I was ever chased
out of a location by
a security guard.
I was walking through the--
there's sort of an
underground.
There's a driveway that went
through Lloyd Center Mall up
in Portland, Oregon.
And we walked through there
because I knew that as you're
driving into the parking lot
properly, like above the
ground, there was drain grates
that I was told by a friend of
mine that yeah, underneath those
drain grates is this
deck where you can drive
through to the
other side of the mall.
So we just walked
through there.
And I was really hoping that the
light would be coming in
nicely through the drain grates,
which once you're down
below, they're above
your head.
So we were walking through in
this dress that we got for $12
at the Salvation Army.
She's like 6 foot
3, this model.
It's a truly, truly tall lady.
And that dress was hanging off
of her, which looked amazing
the way it was just
extra poofy.
So we decided just to
walk through and
try to get some shots.
And we were chased
out by the Segway
security police that day.
And I tried not to laugh at
them when they, [BUZZING],
they buzzed up.
But I figured we had maybe a
minute at most to get the shot
before they were going to come
chase us out of there.
And that's what we got.
And she's not really
levitating.
It's just an effort to just make
something a little more
interesting than it was.
I can show you the before.
So this is the actual reality
of that shot.
Pretty cool, I guess.
I just thought it would be more
interesting if we had her
levitating.
Obviously, done in
post-production.
And where I got the idea for
these kind of tendrily things,
have you ever been to a Hobby
Lobby or a Michael's, is they
have this section were all the
dried floral arrangement
products are.
And these were just some dried,
twiggy, stick things
that we were going to
use for a different
shoot later that month.
And when we got them,
I photographed them.
I was holding those twigs out
at arm's length and just
photographed them, never really
thinking what am I
going to use those for.
I shot them.
And I'm glad I did.
Because I ended pulling those as
a component into this photo
just because.
It's kind of weird,
but why not?
And then the orange stripe
running through the wall was
just more complementary colors
that worked, which I thought
it made it a little
more interesting.
I have sort of a guide built
into my brain with colors.
I have a condition that's
known as synaesthesia.
And I don't know if anyone
here knows what this is.
For those of you who do not,
technically it's a
neurological condition in which
there is a wire crossed
between two of your senses.
And some people with
synaesthesia will have the
ability to say smell numbers,
which I can't even imagine
that happening.
But some people can
taste sounds.
In me, I have a color and
sound association.
In which one color, like I say
we had orange, and if that
orange touches a blue, basically
a musical tone or a
note is produced.
And I will hear that note.
One color, sitting by itself,
doesn't produce any--
it's the interaction of that
color with another color.
So when I'm editing photos and
I'm coming up with a color
palette or whatever, I'm
really forming a
chord within the photo.
We have a chord.
Again, if you don't play music,
we've all sat down at a
keyboard at some point
in your life.
And if you play one note,
well that's just a note.
And if you play two
notes, well now
you've got an interval.
If you play three, now you've
got a chord going on.
And depending on which three
notes you've hit, there's
going to be a mood
to that chord.
Like if it's a minor chord,
it's going sound saddish.
And if it's a major chord, it's
going to sound happy.
And in my mind, this
is how colors are.
So when I come up with a color
palette for a photo, it has to
sound harmonious in my head.
I can't control what
the notes are.
But I can control what colors
I use to make the
chord that I want.
That's my way of perceiving
color.
It's been this way as long
as I can remember.
I actually wasn't diagnosed with
synaesthesia until I was
about 30 years old.
So just last year, basically.
I'll be 44 in a few
weeks actually.
This photo actually was a
compositing experiment.
And talking about stockpiling
elements to composite with
over the years, when I moved
from there Portland, Oregon to
Austin, Texas, which is
where I'm currently
based, I had the ride--
I call it trial by Greyhound.
It was a 60-some hour ride
on a Greyhound bus.
Which if anyone has ever ridden
a Greyhound bus, it's
not a lot of fun.
But I didn't really have
anything to do other than to
take photos.
And what are you going
to take photos of?
I just took photos out the
window of the bus pretty much
the whole journey,
well as long as
the sun was out anyway.
And those trees as you see in
this photo, that's just one of
the bazillion photos I took
while we're going down the
road in the Greyhound.
The whole time taking the
photos, like well, I'm never
going to use these
for anything.
I'm never going to use these.
What am I going to
use them for?
Something told me to take the
photos, so I just took them.
The same thing with the birds
you see in this photo.
Those are two completely
separate photos.
And if you remember the tendrily
things in the photo
with the girl that was floating,
the ones from Hobby
Lobby, we see those
here again.
I sort of brought those
in as another element.
So there's really, there's
four different
photos at work here.
There's the tendrils, and then
there's the birds, and then
there are the trees,
and then the model.
And all I did was just-- well,
I can actually show you the
components of this photo.
Sometimes there's no really
intent necessarily other than
I just want to do some
because it's weird.
And I felt this was weird.
There's no rules.
There's no wrong or right
way to go about this.
That's the photo of the model.
And I just had her just jump.
She boinged about 8, 9
inches off the carpet
and that was it.
And the light is only the--
this is my cheap little
Ikea floor lantern.
I don't want to do a commercial
for Ikea.
But all those weird names of
the products at Ikea-- this
one was called Orgel Vreten.
I'm pronouncing it badly.
I was later told by someone
that knew what that really
meant, it turns out it's not
even a Swedish thing.
I think it was someone
from Norway.
He said it was Organ Eater is
the name of that lamp, the
Organ Eater.
I said organ like--
no, organ like your insides.
I was like I didn't know that.
So this her lit up by the organ
eater lamp, how charming.
And there's the photo of the
trees obviously, out the bus.
And then the tendrily thing
is from the Hobby Lobby.
And all those things combined
equal this.
Like I said, there's not always
an intent or a message.
I was just doing it.
It just looked cool to me.
It's an experiment.
Most of what I do is kind of
an experiment I think.
And this one.
This was the first time ever
worked with someone that does
body painting.
And it was about 12 or 13 hours
just to do the body
paint you see in this.
And what did I do during
those 12 and 13 hours?
I was in charge of snack
acquisition.
I was making tea.
I was making sure everybody
had music
they were happy with.
It was kind of a boring day.
And when it came down do it,
the time I spent actually
shooting was maybe 30
minutes, maybe.
But I just kind of sat
on these photos
for the longest time.
I was like-- this photo, the
final image wasn't produced
for-- it took about five or six
months before I actually
had an idea.
I think a lot of times what I'll
do is shoot, knowing that
the shoot itself is just
part of the process.
So I think a lot of times, in
my weird mind anyway, the
photos have to--
I have to kind of live with
them for a while.
They have to sort of incubate.
And the more I go back, and I'll
look at those photos and
just start getting more of an
idea about maybe what I want
to do with them.
Just looking at them the first
time doesn't necessarily give
me an idea.
And you know, there's photos
you and I have done that
months have rolled by where
I didn't even touch them.
They weren't ready yet.
They're still in the cooker.
And that's just kind
of what happens.
And Shantia is also
a photographer.
And she and I will work
with models that
come through our area.
And you always tell them well,
I'm going to take photos of
you so that you'll have some
instantly, so that you don't
have to get angry waiting
on photos.
Because it's going to take quite
a while for you to get
the photos that he
took of you.
I wish it wasn't that way.
But my brain just takes
a while to let
these things incubate.
And this is a fine example
of one of those.
That's the final image.
The before, not an stunning.
That's the living room at the
house, up against the
thermostat.
That's the controller for the
ceiling fan on the wall.
There's our magic
world in there.
And I think there's a laundry
bin, yeah, back
in the doorway there.
But just a nice, clean
background.
And I know I can drop
something that
I want later on.
She just had this kind of a
goddess look about her.
I tried all kinds of different
backgrounds and stuff.
In the end, just having
a wall-- usually
I'll change the wall.
That just seemed
inappropriate.
So I just figured, hey,
let's go with nature.
And this is what I
ended up with.
Speaking of my lovely, lovely
lady, this is a shot we took.
This was one of the first
shoots we really did.
She looks like some
kind of sailor.
You look like a sailor
or someone
that is a fan of sailors.
I don't know.
The striped shirt just
kind of reminded me.
I think I've already ruined the
surprise with this one.
I was too busy click happy.
But the before version of
this was simply this.
And you can see there's actually
nothing pretty on the
other side of that wall.
I think it was the striped shirt
that made me kind of
think sailor.
And then that breeze stirred
the other breeze.
I was like sailor, well where
would a sailor be hanging out,
maybe in the harbor.
So then I got the idea to
put the harbor in there.
And then the whole complementary
colors and
having the yellow, yellow meets
the blue, which is that
put me obviously out
of the sky, on the
other side of the wall.
It's pretty simple.
There's not much of a concept
other than making some nice
colors and you like sailors.
SHANTIA VENEY: [INAUDIBLE]
JAIME IBARRA: So we're all
familiar with these.
This is the final one, right?
So the before--
and for the first time, now
you know what the heck I'm
talking about.
I think there's a
car out there.
There's like a little raised
parking lot of the ice cream
place next door.
It's good ice cream,
by the way.
And that's it.
That was nice.
I liked the little portholes
that were coming through.
Because I do so much
post-production, I'm always
shooting with post-production
in mind, at least thinking
about the possibilities
of what I could do.
And the first thing I do is kind
of weigh all of the-- or
identify all of the potential
caveats or the potential
problems of that photo.
And try to figure out what it
is I need to deal away with
and try to establish what are
some possibilities, some
directions that I could go with
this, and is everything
ideal to allow that to happen?
So always, always thinking not
necessarily what the final
image of mine.
Because look I said, even if I
think I have an idea of how
I'm going to do the
post-production at the time
I'm shooting it, 99% of the
time that I'm wrong.
That's not at all what
I'm going to--
I'll have this grand idea about
what I think it is I
want to do.
That idea always gets
thrown away.
I never do that one,
like with this.
And I really had no idea what
was going to do with this.
And this one.
Everybody know who
Trey Ratcliff is?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
JAIME IBARRA: So a long time
ago, Trey contacted me for a
post-production session.
He actually paid me--
paid me!--
to take a post-production,
my color grading class.
And I was like is awesome.
And Trey came to my house.
And I'm like this is so cool.
And he walked in and when it
came time for me to show him
my workstation, where I do all
my editing, he was like OK,
yeah, yeah, yeah.
He was like, where's
your pen tablet?
And I was like, yeah, it's
at the Best Buy still.
I keep it on the shelf with the
other ones so it doesn't
get lonely.
And he's like, really?
I was like, yeah, I never
actually had a pen tablet.
And he said that surprises me.
He goes is there a
reason for that?
I was, no.
But not meaning to, but he kind
of made me go well, maybe
I should get one.
And sure enough the next
day, I was like I'm
going to Best Buy.
I going to go get my pen
tablet from them.
And I brought it home and
I hated it, oh my god.
For years and years and years,
I just did everything that I
do with the mouse.
And that's all I knew.
And the thing felt like such
an alien thing in my hands.
And I remember struggling.
I think everyone goes through
this the first time they use a
pen tablet.
I forced myself for two
weeks to use nothing
but my Wacom tablet.
And I used it for everything,
just general computing.
I never used my mouse to
click on anything.
And once it didn't feel so alien
in my hand, I said well,
maybe I can do something
with it.
And I gave up quickly on the
idea of well, maybe the things
that I've been doing with the
mouse this whole time are
going to be so much easier
with the pen.
I put the kibosh on that
idea really quickly.
But it did allow me to do a
lot of things that I could
never have imagined doing
with just the mouse.
And this image was actually
part of that whole
familiarization.
It took me about a week
to produce this.
I probably would do it in a
little bit less time now.
But this image was born out of
my frustration in trying to
familiarize myself with
my pen tablet.
And this photo of the model, the
original photo, was taken
some six or seven years prior
to my doing this whole Wacom
tablet experiment
familiarization operation.
And I never did anything with
the original photo just
because it was nothing
that ever excited me.
I'm going to go to the
original photo.
I'm making sure that you're all
seeing the original photo.
So I'm going to turn head toward
my the screen now.
And come on, hello, that's
the original photo.
And just one more time,
I'm going to go back.
And this is what we ended
up with and this is
the original one.
And in my constant striving for
juxtaposition in a final
image, the sullen,
angry look on her
face is not make believe.
That is she really is
sullen and angry.
We had just walked like 2 and
1/2, 3 miles through some
pretty horrible mosquitoes.
And I think we both have dog
flop on our shoes by the time
we made it through this.
And the silo thing that looks
so potentially amazing from
the street, once we finally
got to it, it was so
disappointing.
And it was hot and it
was just humid.
And we were not having fun.
So this bored kind of like--
she's like oh, my god, just
take the photo, take the
photo, take the photo.
I took the photo and then I
never did anything with it.
But that same bored, I don't
really want to be here
expression in the context of
the original photo, that's
just-- you know, it
is what it is.
But you put this swirling mass
of doom right behind her, with
that same bored expression,
like yeah, OK, yeah, it's
another one of these death
things happening behind me.
I like that juxtaposition
of that.
And that's just an aesthetic
that appeals to me.
It's because I wouldn't be that
stoic and bored if that
was going on behind me.
That was my thought anyway.
And that was my first
experiment.
If you guys remember the--
I kind of a painted in the
hair with Shantia, the
time-lapse video I showed you.
That was actually my first
experiment with visually
painting in hair.
Because her real hair was not
that at all, as you can see.
So baby steps, which is
learning, learning.
I'm still learning.
I think the bit of the dress
that you see that's kind of
floofing out behind her,
obviously that wasn't
happening in this photo.
So I actually borrowed that bit
of dress that you see in
the final image, I borrowed
that bit from a different
photo in that same series.
And I think I probably put three
or four photos together
just to get the dress
material.
And that's just the
way with that one.
And this one, remember the trial
by Greyhound, when I was
going down the road, I was
taking photos out the window
of the Greyhound?
This is one of the photos I
took, not of the model, but
the windmills, the turbines.
What do you call those?
Wind turbines, the
electric ones,
are they still windmills?
They can be.
That's another one of the photos
I took and never did
anything with.
It's just a simple composition
that I just used as a
background for this photo.
That's the original for
the background anyway.
AUDIENCE: Does the original
crop out the head?
JAIME IBARRA: No.
It was my mistake.
When I was doing the photo of
the model, I was actually just
getting my light set up.
I don't shoot usually
in live view.
But I was just kind of looking
at the light and I just
took a quick one.
And I just happened to have
her head chop off.
Maybe it was an accident,
maybe it wasn't.
I don't know.
But nonetheless, her head
was chopped off.
But I ended up oddly enough
using that as the final photo.
And this began sort of a series
of me chopping people's
heads off on purpose
in photos.
And I think it makes you think
a little bit more.
I don't know.
I know this is like if you're
taking photos of people, the
last thing you should
do is like chop
off a limb or a head.
Or you know, you want to keep
them intact as possible.
But I don't know.
It sort of triggers
the imagination.
It's like well, who is she or
what is she doing out by the
windows and stuff?
And you don't know.
And is she pretty?
I mean maybe she's not.
You don't know.
Like I think it just leaves
more to the imagination.
Again, it was actually
kind of an accident.
I don't know why I ended up
going with her head being
chopped off as my
final selection.
It's kind of like the end of
"Lost in Translation" where he
whispers something
into her ear.
You don't know what it
was that he said.
But they seemed happy
about it.
And so you're left to draw your
own conclusions and you
fill in your own blanks there.
And I think if you leave enough
blanks in the story,
people are going to fill in
those blanks as they see fit.
I think some people, like with
me, I imagine in "Lost in
Translation," I imagine he
said something happy.
That was just the way I
perceived it and some other
people might not have imagined
such a thing.
I don't know.
Anybody imagine something
sad in that?
Has anyone else seen
that movie but me?
Has anyone else actually liked
that movie besides me?
OK.
I'm not alone.
See, Pumpkin, I'm not the only
one that likes that movie.
[LAUGHTER]
JAIME IBARRA: But this started
my whole, let's chop people's
heads off in a photo.
I have a whole series
of these that I do.
This is not one of them.
This is a model that
I've shot.
And I found out down
the road the that
actually does fire spinning.
And I remember well.
let's go do it.
And the light that's lighting
her up is really just the
light from the fire.
And she is not exactly
in focus.
But I didn't really think
that was the point.
And I didn't feel that
was important--
and I think the motion
of that.
And the only thing I really did
in post-production was I
dropped in the sky.
And I can show you
the original.
I'm going to turn my head and
make sure you guys are seeing
the original.
OK.
So it's really just trees.
It was like 3:00 in the morning
at this place in
Austin called, yest, the
Enchanted Forest.
And we're down by the creek.
In case she were to catch on
fire, she could just go jump
in the creek really quick.
I remember asking her, I said is
that a good idea for you to
have your hair down while
you're doing that?
She was like, no.
I went OK.
She said well, the water
is right there.
I can just jump in the water.
I'll be OK.
So I just let her do it.
Like hey, she knows
what she's doing.
I'm just here to take
the photos.
All I did was really just sort
of smoothed out the curves
that the flames are making in
that photo and then just
dropped in the sky.
And like I'm a huge fan
of orange meets blue.
I mean you have the orange tones
in her skin and in the
fire meets that blue sky.
And in my mind, that's like
one of the nicest sounds.
And we've got quite a bit of
orange meets blue in our
house, don't we?
And my tattoos, I had
very similar--
I wanted control over what
colors touch what colors.
I was like I'm going to be
looking at this all day long.
I want it to be something
I'm OK with looking at.
And so there's a lot of
orange touching blue.
And you'll see a lot of orange
meets blue in my photos.
And that's just an aesthetic
tendency that I lean towards.
And let's go to this one.
And this is Shantia again
in a bowling alley.
How often do you get to shoot
in a bowling alley?
You don't, oddly.
You can't walk out in
the lane anyway.
But we were able to at
this place one night.
I have no before version.
These are the last few photos
that I have for you.
But there's no before.
These are just the final.
And again, orange meets blue.
There's rather a lot of orange
meets blue in this one.
AUDIENCE: Was that deliberate
putting the crown on her head?
JAIME IBARRA: What's that?
What's that?
Will you repeat?
AUDIENCE: Was it deliberate
putting the crown on her head?
JAIME IBARRA: People have
asked that question.
Actually I didn't notice it.
I don't know if you did.
But you know what somebody
else noticed?
Yeah, I think the fingers, her
fingers are mimicking the
trifecta of awesomeness with
the crown above her head.
And that wasn't necessarily
intentional.
Your reason for doing your
fingers that way were?
SHANTIA VENEY: It's the most
graceful position to put your
hands in because that's where
all your weight is.
JAIME IBARRA: Yeah.
It's most graceful-- did
everybody hear that?
I'll repeat that.
It's the most graceful position
to put your hand in
down there because she knows
what she's doing in front of
the camera.
It just looks pretty.
And yeah, I didn't notice
any of that.
But yeah, a lot of people have
asked that about the crown.
Actually I should just
go yep, yeah.
We knew exactly.
That's exactly the case.
So that's our shot at
the bowling alley.
Actually, this poor girl
actually sprained her foot in
this shoot.
And we had tried and tried and
tried many, many times to get
her to jump.
She's actually maybe a foot and
a half off the ground in
this photo.
Anything that I'm going to
show you from here out, I
don't have the originals
of these.
But I just simply extended the
height of the siding wall that
we're shooting against.
So just make it look like you
don't know how high up we are.
But I remember when she jumped,
she just went sailing.
And then when she landed, I just
remember it sounded like
a five pound ham hit
the sidewalk.
It was like smack.
I was oh, that can't be good.
And she goes, we're done.
But that was the last photo
that we got that day.
And mercifully, it came
out really nice.
I like to shoot a lot of fabric,
like flying fabric.
That was one of my early
successes with that.
This one, we couldn't really
get much that day.
And I remember it was me and
a small team of people,
including the model.
And the model had brought a
bunch of stuff, just scarves.
She had a bunch of scarves in
a bag and different clothes.
And I remember out of
frustration we were like--
we weren't getting results that
I was really happy with.
So we decided OK, let's
take a break.
So we said well, what else
do you have with you
today, like what else?
And I didn't ask
that question.
My stylist that day asked
So in this photo, she's looking
over at the stylist.
But the stylist said well, pick
that up and hold it up.
And by the third or fourth time,
she reached down and
grabbed different scarves.
And was holding the
scarves out.
She was holding them
out towards me,
kind of an arm's length.
And she's OK, that's cool.
Let me see that one, let
me see this one,
let me see that one.
But when she held this one
up, it's at arm's length.
And she's got her head turned
and she's looking at my--
she's talking to my
stylist actually.
So I just shot through
the scarf as she
was holding it up.
And it was kind of sort of a
happy accident, sort of, which
I get quite a lot of those.
Sometimes accidents are good.
But you have to make these
moments happen.
And my stylist that day was
a little more experienced.
This one goes back
many, many years.
And I realize now what
she would doing.
She was trying to get the model
to pick up the different
pieces of clothes.
She's creating opportunities
for me to shoot.
But I think I caught on.
I was oh, I see what
you're doing.
OK, I got it now.
But now, I'm more cognizant
of these things.
You do have to create
moments like this.
This juxtaposition in my mind,
this is the last couple you
would ever expect to see out in
the pretty, pretty, pretty
field of flowers.
And I remember I was driving
over to get my
tattoo worked on.
The lady in the photo
is my tattoo artist
and that's her husband.
One of the few weddings that
I've ever photographed and
actually enjoyed.
But I remember I was driving out
to get my tattoo worked on
and I went a different route to
where she works and drove--
I was like that's an actual
field of sunflowers.
I never see that.
And I was thinking like what
model could I get to
photograph in front
of the sunflowers?
And I went no, wait.
And I remember where
I was going.
And it's like I'm going to
get them to do this.
And of course, they
loved the idea.
It was like sunflowers, like
no one's ever asked us that
ever, ever.
It's was like let's do it.
Then we got chased out of
that property actually.
We were shooting-- we were
just on the sidewalk.
And there's a kind of main
thoroughfare that went through.
And as I was standing
and shooting, this
pickup truck pulls up.
He's like, what are you doing?
What are you doing?
It was like oh, something
bad I guess.
I said oh, we're just
shooting it.
And I said, is this
your property?
He was like yeah, those
are my flowers too.
And I was like, OK.
He goes what are you doing?
And I made up this thing.
I said oh, they're
a famous band.
He goes who?
You know I never
heard of them.
And I said oh, they're called
Trampoline Stroganoff actually.
I said, I don't like them.
The kids do.
And I said we'll be done in
just-- they're famous.
And he goes, two minutes and
I'm gong to call the cops.
And I was like does that mean
we have two minutes to shoot
and then you're going to call
the cops or you're going to
call them in two minutes
regardless?
And he was like two minutes.
And I was like, OK.
And I think I took a couple more
photos after that, me and
Trampoline Stroganoff.
And then we boogied out.
That's my Trampoline
Stroganoff story.
They're not really a band.
They should be.
But more people with their
heads chopped off.
That really is her camera.
She really does use it.
And I think that photo says
enough about her.
You don't really need to see her
head to get the idea about
her as a person.
You got the black nail polish
and you got her thumb ring.
And she's a rebel, with her
vintage dress and her old
school film camera, but
with just no head.
And hey, guess what,
more people with
their heads cut off.
At this one, there's a small
photo of her you can kind of
see in there.
And does anyone else find these
interesting at all?
If mean if you don't, you don't
have to say yes just to
make me happy.
But you do, right?
I mean I think there's
something
interesting about them.
It's not aesthetically pleasing
to most, but--
AUDIENCE: I think the photo,
in the photo she should be
holding the Polaroid as well.
JAIME IBARRA: Yeah.
That's a good idea.
Say one breathe, to
another breathe.
And the next time I do one
of these, we'll do that.
And that will be
my nod to you.
AUDIENCE: Just have her
whole bag be Polaroid.
JAIME IBARRA: Exactly.
Yeah, good idea.
Guess what, this time not only
did I chop the head off, I got
rid of the whole torso
pretty much.
And this remains one of the most
viewed photos that I've
ever taken.
And I am not able to put
my finger on why
and I always wonder.
Like I had this up for a while
on "DeviantART." And it got
like 1.6 million views
on this one photo.
And I was thinking like if I
could figure out what it is
that's making people want to
look at this photo and just
replicate that from here on out,
this is one of the things
that's got me.
To this day, I scratch my head
and wonder what it is about it
that garnered so many views and
it had so much attention?
Any guesses?
AUDIENCE: Does the model have
a ballet background?
JAIME IBARRA: No, actually.
No.
AUDIENCE: Standing
on her tiptoes.
JAIME IBARRA: No.
And the reality of this was
she had just showed up to
shoot for a couple of days and
she was all excited to show us
all the clothes and stuff
that she had brought.
And she had just drove all the
way from New York and everyone
was having a little
bit to drink.
And there's a little tiny, tiny,
tiny bit of wine left in
that glass right there.
And that's what we are having.
But she was in the process-- we
were having a glass of wine
and she wanted to show us her
friend's red shoes that she
stole, or borrowed.
"Sorry."
And she goes, oh, you got
to check these out.
So she runs over.
And she put them on and at the
same time tried on this
vintage dress.
And she came back in the room.
And she was just showing
us the shoes.
And while she was showing the
shoes, I was taking photos of
the whole thing.
And that's how I ended
up just getting it.
It was rather not
planned at all.
AUDIENCE: Did you
crop it in post?
JAIME IBARRA: This is
how it ended up.
Yeah, I did not crop this
one in post at all.
She was just running into the
other room, trying on
something, and run
into this room.
And I would go, OK, good,
click, click, click.
And she'd run off and just
rinse and repeat.
And so we had a better idea of
what we were going to shoot
the next day and just kind of
planned out the wardrobe.
So this is just one of the
outfits that she quickly
changed into.
That's really all I have
to say about that one.
Another one, we were
doing laundry.
Oop, thank you.
Well, what you'll see is the
most amazing photo you've ever
seen in your life when
it decides to change.
So I can go ahead and prime
the story for you.
Well literally, we're
doing laundry.
And would help if I click back
and maybe kind of kick it a
little bit?
No.
It didn't help, did it?
AUDIENCE: Now, you know why
that one's viewed so much.
[LAUGHTER]
JAIME IBARRA: Because you
can't click off of
it, there you go.
That's it, yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Did you have light
set up for this picture?
JAIME IBARRA: With the one with
the legs and the shoes,
there was some.
Although I do want to
point out I almost
never use studio lighting.
To this day, I own one camera
body, one lens.
And the extent of my equipment
ends there.
Well, actually we have
a tripod now.
So there's a third piece
of studio gear was
added to the arsenal.
It's a rather cheap, shoddy
tripod as well.
SHANTIA VENEY: To take
pictures of clouds.
JAIME IBARRA: To take pictures
of the clouds.
No.
Yeah, there was some light
set up in that shot.
But that was not my light.
It was the light that belonged
to my friend, whose house we
were in at the time.
But most of the time, I just
shoot whatever is available.
I not object to using
studio light.
I just don't own any.
But you will see studio lighting
pop up every now and
again in my shots.
But it's kind of rare.
And this was I was just
doing laundry one day.
And this is kind of serendipity
I guess.
So I was like the laundrette
that we went to was not the
normal one we would
normally go to.
I said "not" and negatives
a lot in that one
sentence, didn't I?
It's not the one we didn't not
never not go to, normally not.
So the one we normally went
to was really crowded.
So we ended up having to go down
the street another mile.
And this particular one happened
to have these really
brightly colored industrial
dryers along this one wall.
And it just so happened that
she was wearing these
ridiculous stockings.
And it looks like
we planned it.
But we honestly didn't.
And we almost got kicked
out when she decided to
climb into the dryer.
And I think had we not already
had 12 actual loads of wash
going, we would have
been kicked out.
AUDIENCE: More orange
and blue.
JAIME IBARRA: Yeah.
More orange meets blue, yup.
But again, that was just
luck of the draw.
This was not planned
in any way.
But I liked it a lot.
And look, it's another photo
without someone's head.
Can you see that the interest
I guess it would generate.
If you were like this, well,
who's in the dryer?
I mean how people actually wish
they could see her head?
All of you who didn't raise
your hand are correct.
That's exactly right.
AUDIENCE: Doesn't she
look like one
of the wicked witches?
JAIME IBARRA: I'm not
going to say.
I'm not answering
that question--
I'll answer that question
afterwards.
But I won't do it while
this is being filmed.
SHANTIA VENEY: It's not me.
JAIME IBARRA: It's
not Shantia.
Yeah, I actually named this
photo "Reprobate," which is
something my mother
used to call me.
I never knew what
that word meant.
Everybody knows what
reprobate means.
It's not a nice thing to call
your kid, I found out later.
If I was doing something wrong,
she was like, hey,
reprobate, go clean your room
or don't do that any more.
It's not a nice thing.
So that's the name of this
photo, "Reprobate," if that
gives you any idea.
I don't think there's any photos
of you with your head
chopped off.
SHANTIA VENEY: Not yet.
JAIME IBARRA: Not yet.
Be nice.
SHANTIA VENEY: I got to do
something really wrong.
JAIME IBARRA: Yeah.
You have to do something
really wrong first.
And we're back to this again.
So I kind of plowed through
those a little
quicker than I thought.
So actually if anyone has any
questions, I'll open up the
floor to that.
AUDIENCE: The model who you shot
in front of the silo and
then you put the tornado in
front of her seven years
later, or behind her, did
you still keep in
contact with her?
Were you able to give her
the final product?
JAIME IBARRA: Yes.
AUDIENCE: What did she think?
JAIME IBARRA: She said
oh, that's cool.
AUDIENCE: It was like
seven years later.
JAIME IBARRA: Yeah,
seven later.
OK, well, thanks.
That's cool, I guess.
When possible, I do keep in
touch with everyone that I've
photographed.
You know how people kind of fade
in and out of your life.
But yeah, I think
she liked it.
She's not a very expressive
person by nature.
So maybe it meant to be more
complimentary than it sounded.
But yeah, I think
she liked it.
AUDIENCE: So obviously
you can do
amazing things with Photoshop.
So I'm curious why bother
putting the models in front of
sunflowers or in bowling alleys,
where you could easily
do that on your own?
JAIME IBARRA: Because I'd
rather not have to spend
hours, and hours, and
hours, and hours,
and hours in Photoshop.
AUDIENCE: Aren't you going
to change it anyway?
JAIME IBARRA: Not necessarily.
Like for instance, with
this one, there really
wasn't much to change.
I mean I guess that's
a good point.
I mean we could have just
shot in the house.
And I could have just shot
you against a wall.
And then if I had already
taken this
photo, at one point--
SHANTIA VENEY: There's
something to be said
for doing it right.
JAIME IBARRA: Oh yeah,
that's exactly it.
There's something to be said
for doing it right and get
getting it right from
the get-go.
It's kind of a safety net.
I guess if it didn't look
exactly like I wanted it to
when I was shooting, knowing
that you could make it that
way in post-production.
It's just a nice feeling to know
that it could be done.
But it's easier and better if
you can just have everything
in place when you're actually
taking the photos.
AUDIENCE: As long as nobody is
behind me, one other question?
So these models, how do they
feel about when they get their
photo back without their head?
JAIME IBARRA: I have not
been complemented too
many times like that.
But usually like they've gotten
a bunch of other photos
with their head.
So this is like them receiving
a headless one, that was just
kind of a one off,
they're-- oh.
Yeah, I've received like
that face a lot.
They would look at the photo
and they go OK, well, you
don't have to like that one.
But I've given them other
photos with their head.
But a couple of people with
their heads chopped off
actually liked them.
The girl with the glass
of wine and the red
shoes, she liked it.
So it's not an always
thing, but yeah.
Anyone else?
Any other questions?
What's that?
AUDIENCE: Is the blowing
hair there real?
Or was that in post-production?
JAIME IBARRA: It was in post.
It was all painted digitally
with my Wacom tablet skills
that I gained.
AUDIENCE: Well, so how exactly
did you do that?
How did you paint the hair?
It seems like kind of
it's not nontrivial.
JAIME IBARRA: It seems
what, I'm sorry?
AUDIENCE: Like nontrivial, it
seems like pretty hard to
doing something like that.
JAIME IBARRA: It took a while.
I did it with the
Wacom tablet.
I have special brushes that
were actually made for
creating hair in an
illustration.
They were passed on to me by a
friend of mine who does a lot
of illustrations for book
covers, with her publishing
company that she works with.
And she was gracious enough to
pass along all of her brushes
she used to create hair with.
But they don't make it easy.
But they're a good
starting point.
But there's probably a 1,000 to
2,000 strokes of the brush
at work to get this to happen.
So it's is a gradual thing.
It just builds, and it builds,
and it builds, and it builds,
and it builds.
And yeah, it takes a while,
it takes a while to do.
But we couldn't control
the wind that day.
And we really didn't have
much control that day.
So there's a good example of
when post-production can come
in and save the shot.
That's the hair.
It takes a little
bit of patience.
It's not for everybody,
I don't think.
But I'd rather have a nice
fan and her real
hair blowing amazingly.
That would have been
so much better.
But how many hours did I
spend doing that hair?
SHANTIA VENEY: Quite
a long time.
JAIME IBARRA: A pretty long
time, several hours.
Many a meal could've been baked
in the time it took.
SHANTIA VENEY: Many
a meal was baked.
JAIME IBARRA: Many a meal
was baked actually.
Yeah, it's like she's
a chef, too.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Can you talk a little
bit about the lack of
contrast in your final works?
It's very aesthetic.
I like it.
But it seems like a lot of
photographers try to push the
contrast to the max in their
final output image.
How do your feel contrasts or
the lack of it fits in your
artistic sense?
JAIME IBARRA: Well, I'm assuming
you're talking about
luminosity contrasts.
Because it looks fairly
washed out, right?
OK.
So like to me, contrast can
exist in the luminosity realm.
But there's also
color contrast.
And I see plenty of
And I guess in my aesthetic,
that color contrast meets my
contrast needs I guess.
But I think the washed out, kind
of faded look maybe stems
from some nostalgic thing
when I was a child.
And one of the things I used to
do when we would go to my
grandmother's house is the first
thing I would do was
sneak down to the basement and
pull out these boxes of old
photos that she collected.
And just I liked looking at
those old faded photos.
And maybe the seed was
planted then for
this part of my aesthetic.
But I don't necessarily look
for luminosity contrast.
I look for color contrast.
Like there's the yellows and
greens in the terrain.
If those meet a cooler color,
kind of like they are in the
sky with the cloud, to
me, that's contrast.
And there's no mistaking where
the two things meet.
So there's enough contrast
in there, in my opinion.
But I'm not after these really
sharp, like sharp luminosity
contrast photos.
Like a lot of the photos I was
drawn to just as a child were
like the old photos I
would find in a box.
So I'm guessing maybe that's
where it came from.
It's just a leftover,
nostalgic thing that
influenced my aesthetic sense.
Thank you.
Thank you very much
for having me.
[APPLAUSE]